[ Crowd cheers ]
-3...2...1.
[ Imitates buzzer ]
That's it!
Good game, pal. I won.
I don't know who you are,
but it was fun
playing against you.
-You didn't win. I won.
-What?
-No, you didn't.
Look at the score.
-Stop the count.
-We did stop the count,
and I won.
-Keep counting.
-I don't need to.
Look at the scoreboard.
-We're demanding a recount,
folks.
Can you can believe this?
I'm being totally cheated.
Everyone agrees.
I'm in the process of suing
PlayStation right now.
-What, uh -- President Trump?
-Fake news!
-Oh, come on, just admit you
lost so we can all move on.
Besides, don't you have
more important things to do
to be playing video games?
-I could ask you the same thing.
-It's time for the show.
I gotta go.
-Hey, Dad, can I play?
-Get out of there, Eric!
-I'm Don Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-From Rockefeller Center,
in the heart of
New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests --
Chance the Rapper,
Erin Andrews,
musical guests
G Herbo and Chance the Rapper --
and featuring the legendary
Roots crew.
And now here he is --
JimmyFallon!
-Do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
Hey! Thank you!
Hello, and welcome!
Thank you very much.
Please.
That is so nice.
Oh, my goodness!
Oh, that's
what I'm talking about!
Thank you, thank you, thank you
very much.
Wow. What a crowd.
You're not gonna believe this,
but the White House
just told me
we got a million people
in here tonight.
Amazing, amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amazing.
Well, let's get to
the news and jokes.
Well, guys, as the pandemic
gets worse,
President Trump is making it
even tougher
for President-Elect Biden
to deal with the crisis.
Apparently, he's still not
letting
his coronavirus task force
talk to Biden's.
I'm really shocked by this,
'cause, up until now,
Trump's handling of the pandemic
has been flawless.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, why is it
so hard for Trump?
He's been passing off COVID
responsibilities
for eight months.
Why stop now?
[ Laughter ]
I'm not surprised the transition
of power is taking so long.
Every time Mike Pence hears
the word "transition,"
he runs and hides under the bed.
[ Laughter ]
"Mother, put on
'David and Goliath.'"
[ Laughter ]
Not sure any of this matters.
Trump's task force probably
wrote like one memo that says,
"We think you get it
from licking stuff."
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, do we even want
Trump's task force
training Biden's?
That's like
getting legal advice
from Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
"I'd like to represent myself."
But here's some good news.
After last week's announcement
from Pfizer
that their vaccine is
more than 90% effective,
another company, Moderna,
has made an announcement
of their own.
Watch this.
-This morning, breaking news
on the coronavirus vaccine.
Moderna announcing its vaccine
could be up to 94.5% effective.
-That's an amazing achievement.
Scientists are like,
"We've harnessed
the power of mRNA,"
while Americans are like,
"Does it come in grape flavor?"
[ Laughter ]
"Can I get it in the gummy shape
like Fred Flintstone?"
[ Laughter ]
I had to read that joke
as Brian Regan,
'cause it felt like --
it sounded like
Brian would have nailed that,
so that was for you, Brian.
[ As Brian Regan ]
A gummy like --
like, Fred Flintstone
type of gummy.
Bet I could do that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Meanwhile,
this weekend in Washington,
Trump supporters gathered
to protest the election.
And Trump even drove by
on his way to the golf course.
Take a look.
-Mr. Trump saluted a rally
from his motorcade
as thousands of Trump supporters
claimed election fraud.
-Yeah, nothing says
"Thanks for your support"
like barreling through the crowd
on your way to a golf course.
[ Laughter ]
If you read his lips,
I think he's saying,
"They wasted a Saturday
for this?
Could have gone golfing."
[ Laughter ]
Can we show it again?
Just him going by his followers?
-Mr. Trump saluted a rally
from his motorcade...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, man.
And this was cute.
Trump's car -- I don't know
if you saw it --
even had a bunch of tin cans
hanging off the back
and a sign that said,
"Just Lost the Election."
I don't know.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Trump was overwhelmed
by the support.
And he was like,
"I love you guys.
You're doing the white thing.
I mean, the right thing."
[ Laughter ]
Well, if it's not clear by now,
Trump still isn't ready
to move on from the election.
But yesterday,
for the first time,
it seemed like he was admitting
that Biden won.
Trump tweeted, "He won because
the election was rigged."
Yep, that might be as close
to a concession speech
as we're gonna get, folks.
But it was short-lived,
because he went on to say,
"I concede nothing,"
and, "I won the election."
[ Laughter ]
Trump won't give up,
while the rest of us are like,
"Dude, we've moved on
to Netflix shows about chess.
We -- We don't care.
We don't care, dude."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even though Trump's lawsuits
keep getting tossed out,
it's clear the president
is not planning to concede
anytime soon.
So you know what?
We thought we'd do it for him
and give us
the concession speech
that we all deserve.
Take a look.
[ "America the Beautiful"
plays ]
-My fellow Americans,
a short time ago,
Joe Biden beat me
in the election.
And not only did he win,
he won by a lot, actually.
Therefore, it is time
for me to step aside.
Because, let's face it,
I wasn't probably on my game,
and I wasn't doing so well.
And you know, I'm the only
President in history
to lose the popular vote twice
and to get impeached.
It's time
for a change.
The greatest dream in the world
is that Joe Biden wins,
because the winner of this vote
was decided
by a fair and open election.
Therefore, I humbly concede
to Joe Biden.
The American people
have responded.
And they have said to me,
"You're fired.
Bing. Get out."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of the election,
The Gap says
sales of their pants
have nearly doubled
since the election week,
and they think
it has something to do
with Steve Kornacki.
[ Laughter ]
Watch this.
After many news outlets reported
that Kornacki's signature khakis
come from The Gap,
the company reported it saw
a dramatic increase
in online traffic
and a more than 90% sales
increase on khaki pants.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Right now, Anna Wintour is like,
"Why did I choose Harry Styles
for the cover of 'Vogue'?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Kornacki!"
"I told you -- Kornacki!"
[ Laughter ]
Today, middle-aged white guys
were like,
"Is this the line for the PS5s
or the Kornacki khakis?"
[ Laughter ]
Republicans don't know
how to feel right now.
They lost the White House,
but khakis are back.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually really impressive,
because if there's one thing
Americans haven't been buying
during the pandemic, it's pants.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
Costco is now offering
its members a new service.
Listen to this.
-There's a new membership option
at Costco.
Private jet company Wheels Up
has partnered with the retailer
to offer 12-month memberships
for its service,
starting at the low, low price
of $17,500.
-As if someone is gonna be
shopping like, "Okay,
I got the whole chicken,
I got a box of Go-Gurt,
uh, toilet paper,
and, oh, I almost forgot,
I need that, uh,
jet membership."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Can I try reading it
as Brian Regan again?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Brian Regan ] Let's see,
I got the whole chicken,
got a box of Go-Gurt,
I got the toilet paper.
Uh, almost forgot, I need
that jet membership!
[ Normal voice ] Nah,
that's not it.
[ Applause ]
It's not working as good.
This is cool, though.
Since it's Costco, they
come around midflight
and offer everyone
a 10-gallon drum of peanuts.
I thought that was good.
Hey, guys,
Thanksgiving is next week,
And I saw that Baskin-Robbins
has brought back
its turkey ice cream cake.
Take a look.
There it is.
Because all kids were like,
"If only our favorite treat
looked more like
a dead bird carcass.
Unh!"
[ Laughter ]
What is that?
It looks like
they spray-painted
Thor's helmet.
[ Laughter ]
Not to be outdone, Cinnabon
just started selling
its frosting by the pint.
Look at this. Wow.
That's right, it's all the fun
of eating Cinnabon
with double the depression.
It's perfect for anyone looking
to Flex Seal their arteries.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, this is great.
Now I have something to baste
the Baskin-Robbins turkey with.
[ Laughter ]
Here's a crazy story
from overseas.
A school in France
had to ask parents
to stop throwing their kids over
the 6-foot gate
when they showed up late
for school.
Check out the sign that they
actually had to hang up.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's dangerous.
Apparently,
while landing on the other side,
some kids broke
their wine bottle.
[ French accent ] Now what will
I pair with my Lunchables?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Meanwhile,
the parents
are already one step ahead.
Now they're taking
stale baguettes
and making their kids
pole-vault over the fence.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckling ]
And finally, a scuba diver
off the coast of Egypt
just set an amazing new record.
Take a look at this.
-An Egyptian scuba diver has
broken a new world record.
He spent 145 hours, or almost
six whole days, underwater.
-Wow. Yeah.
Yeah, he came up,
learned it was still 2020,
and went back down.
Well, guys,
here's some fun news.
Last night, we won
a People's Choice Award!
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We won for Nighttime Talk Show
of 2020.
It's so cool.
I just want to thank the
People's Choice Awards.
And thank you to everyone
who voted for us.
This award is always special
because it comes from you,
the people.
We try to put on the best show
we can for you guys every night,
and it's a real honor
to be awarded.
So thank you so much again
for that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's cool.
I'll pass it around.
Everyone gets it for a weekend,
yeah.
-Okay, cool. Cool.
-Guys, it's Monday.
We're excited to be back.
We have a great week of shows
coming up.
Sarah Paulson will be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dan Levy will be here.
Michael J. Fox
will be on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got music performances
from Julia Michaels
and Dierks Bentley!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big week.
And be sure to tune in
Wednesday night.
Oh, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Something cool is going down.
Something
never before attempted.
-Oh!
We're having a pajama party here
in the studio.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See? People like it.
A "Tonight Show
P'Jimmy Jammy Jam."
More on that
as the week progresses.
[ Laughter ]
-P'Jimmy Jammy Jam?
-It's a P'Jimmy Jammy Jam.
-So, what, a pajama party
has never attempted?
-Never been attempted.
-Wow. Awesome.
-Not on "The Tonight Show."
-We can wear --
-Not on television, even.
-Oh, ok-- Well...
-This is unprecedented.
-Okay.
-What you're about to do,
Wednesday -- I mean, I would --
-Wait, what I'm about to do?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, yeah, we're in this
together, man.
We're a team.
-We have to wear p'Jimmies?
-You "got to" or you "get to"?
[ Laughter ]
You "get to" wear p-Jimmies.
-Okay.
-On Wednesday night, and you
get to just jam down, dude.
And party down.
This is gonna be a par-tay.
You see what I'm saying? No.
-No, no.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-You won't even believe --
When you see --
You know what you should do?
You should just get a hotel
in the city.
Because there's no way you're
gonna want to go back home.
Gonna just want to
stay up all night,
rent movies, and
just hang out with your friends.
Who do you got?
We have Julia Michaels
Wednesday.
-Right.
-That's all we know so far.
-That's it.
-So we can dance -- She has
a song we can dance to.
-In our pajamas?
-In our pajamas, yeah.
-Okay.
-Yep.
She will not be wearing pajamas.
-Oh.
-But we will.
-Okay.
-Well, I mean, you can't --
it's our party.
-Okay.
-See what I'm saying?
-Will the audience in
attendance be wearing pajamas?
-That's a great question.
They will, actually.
-Ah.
-The audience will.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They want it.
People need this now.
Everyone's living
their whole days in pajamas.
-Yeah, that's -- I --
-Wait till you see what it is.
Again, I can't give
any more information
than I have already have.
I already said too much.
-Okay.
-But yet not enough.